hey this is presh talwalker
you have a painting that you want to
hang up on the wall
you can imagine your viewing angle of
the painting which is your viewing angle
between the bottom and the top of the
painting
this will obviously depend on many
dimensions
suppose this point is O which is
parallel to your eyesight
the wall is perpendicular to that and
suppose the top and bottom of the
paintings are points A and B
let's say OB is equal to 18 and a b is
equal to 14.
suppose your eyesight is at Point p
obviously As you move closer or farther
away you will change the viewing angle
APB
so if you move very close in byte change
if you go very far away it might change
so the question is what distance should
you be viewing the painting at that is
what is the length op such that the
angle APB is maximum
I think fam for the suggestion
as an interesting historical note this
was asked in a letter by Regio montanus
in 1471.
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
I will present two different ways to
solve the problem
one method primarily uses trigonometry
and the classical method actually was
using geometry
so let's get started with trigonometry
because this is a typical problem that
students are asked today
so let's set up the problem we'll start
with the coordinate system suppose the
point O is at 0 0
B is at zero comma B A is at zero comma
A and P is that X come zero
let's label the angle APB as Theta
let's land both the angle APO as Alpha
and we'll label the angle BPO as beta
now Theta is equal to Alpha minus beta
and Theta is an angle between 0 and 90
degrees
so we want to maximize Theta
now in the range 0 to 90 degrees tangent
is an increasing function so this is
equivalent to maximizing the tangent of
theta
why are we going to do that
well let's work it out
since Theta is equal to Alpha minus beta
we can substitute the tangent of theta
is equal to tangent of alpha minus beta
and then we can use the tangent formula
for the difference of angles this is
equal to tangent Alpha minus tangent
beta all over 1 plus tangent Alpha times
tangent beta
now we can solve for tangent Alpha and
tangent beta using the triangles
so here in this large triangle APO we
see that tangent Alpha is equal to the
opposite side which has length a divided
by the adjacent side which has length x
so tangent Alpha is equal to a over X
in Triangle BPO we can solve that
tangent beta is equal to B divided by X
so now let's just focus on these
formulas
we will substitute in for tangent Alpha
and tangent beta
we now want to simplify this a
convenient trick will be to multiply the
numerator and denominator by x squared
so that we can get rid of the fractions
in the numerator and the denominator
so the numerator will become X
multiplied by a minus B and the
denominator will become x squared plus a
b
so why have we done all this work
what we have now done is we have set up
the problem so that we have a function
of X this is a function of only the
variable X because A and B are unknown
constants
we now want to maximize this value
so that will be equivalent to maximizing
f of x
a standard way to do this is to use
calculus
we'll take the derivative and we're
taking the derivative of a quotient so
you could remember the derivative of a
quotient or a of high divided by low the
derivative of this is equal to low D
High minus high D low all over low
squared
so we can substitute in here
it'll be quite a complicated derivative
but don't worry it'll simplify quite a
bit
so F Prime of X is equal to low that's x
squared plus a b multiplied by the
derivative of high that's the numerator
X multiplied by the quantity a minus B
minus high D low so high is the
numerator X multiplied by a minus B
multiplied by the derivative of the
denominator which is x squared plus a b
this is all divided by the denominator x
squared plus a b the entire quantity
squared
so the derivative of x multiplied by a
minus B is just going to be a minus B
and the derivative of x squared plus a b
is equal to 2X
so we can substitute those in
now let's just simplify a little bit
more
we can multiply the X by the 2x to get
2x squared now in the numerator we can
factor in a minus B
so we'll get a minus B multiplied by a B
minus x squared this is all over x
squared plus a b that whole quantity
squared
so let's look at this derivative F Prime
of x
so one term is a minus B and this is an
unknown constant now a is the distance
to the top of the painting B is the
distance to the bottom of the painting
So a minus B will be greater than zero
now what about the denominator we have
the square of x squared plus a b
now we know that A and B are greater
than zero so the square of x squared
plus a b will also be greater than zero
so the sine of the derivative only
depends on the sign of the other term
which is a B minus x squared
so there are three cases to consider
if x squared is less than a b the
derivative will be positive if x squared
is equal to a b then a B minus x squared
will be equal to zero the whole
derivative will vanish and if x squared
is greater than a b then the derivative
will be negative
so we see the derivative
is going to be positive until x squared
equals a b then it's negative that means
the function is increasing until x
squared equals a b and then it's
decreasing
so when x squared is equal to a b the
function has a maximum
we can solve this that X is equal to the
positive square root of a b we of course
want a positive distance on the right
side
so that's our solution X is equal to the
square root of a b and a and b are
unknown constants
now just for fun I want to show you
another way that we could have done this
optimization so let's say we get to the
step we want to maximize this tangent of
this angle
and we have a function of x
so instead of using calculus here's
another way to approach it you could use
the amgm inequality that's the
inequality of the arithmetic mean and
geometric mean
so maximizing this fraction is
equivalent to minimizing the reciprocal
of the fraction
now A minus B is a positive unknown
constant
so we can just ignore this term it has
nothing to do with X so this is
equivalent to minimizing x squared plus
a b all over X
so let's simplify this fraction if we
divide through by X this is equal to X
plus a b divided by X
we now have two terms
we can now apply the amgm inequality
that this sum of these two terms is
greater than or equal to two times the
square root of the product of these two
terms this is the amgm inequality
and interestingly
the minimum will happen when you have
equality
and that will happen exactly when these
two terms are equal to each other
so the minimum occurs when X is equal to
a b divided by X and that means that x
squared is equal to a b or X is equal to
the square root of a b so it's kind of
fun to know there's a different way to
solve this problem that you don't have
to do that complicated derivative and
analyze it very carefully you could
apply this amgm inequality to figure out
that X is equal to the square root of a
b
so let's apply this formula to our
problem
so the point B is that zero comma 18
then we add 14 to get that to point a is
at zero comma 32 and we want to solve
for the point P which is X comma zero
so applying that a is equal to 32 and B
is equal to 18 x is equal to the square
root of 32 multiplied by 18 and that
works out very conveniently to be 24
units and that's the answer
so now let's work out the problem in
another way which is using geometry so
most students learn the problem in
Calculus class but by way of History
this problem was posed in 1471 and
modern calculus as we know it did not
exist so how did they even approach the
problem in those days they used
geometric Concepts and while it's a
little bit of a magical solution in that
if you know what the correct answer is
you can show that it's the correct
answer I still think it's interesting to
show that geometry can be used as some
way to approach these problems
so here's how we set up the problem
let's say we have a line L right here
that goes through Point O that's
perpendicular to the line
ve we're going to construct a circle
through the points A and B that's
tangent to the line L there's actually a
unique circle that'll do this on the
right hand side so let's see how that
works
so the first step is take this length OB
and copy it above the point a
call this point B Prime
construct a circle with diameter B Prime
o
then from the point B construct a
perpendicular to the diameter
label this point as C
draw a line through C that's
perpendicular to the line L
then
call this point P this will actually be
the optimum point
Now call this point M which is the
midpoint of a b and construct the
perpendicular bisector of a b
so where this intersects with the line
going through PC called this point e
this will be the center of the circle so
we have circle e with radius e p
so this will be needed in our proof
so let's just focus on this circle the
points a B and P so amazingly p is the
solution that's the point at which you
should stand it'll be the circle that's
tangent to the line L that goes through
the points A and B
this is absolutely amazing so why is
this a solution
so to see why
let's construct another Point P Prime on
L which is different from p
so we have one angle BPA and we have
another angle B P prime a and we want to
prove that the angle BPA has a greater
measure than the angle B P prime a
so how can we do that
this will involve some geometric
Concepts
so first construct the point Q which is
the intersection of B P Prime with the
circle
then construct AQ
now what can we say about the angle b q
a
it'll exactly be equal to the angle BPA
because both of these are inscribed
angles in the circle of the same Arc a b
next consider angle q a p Prime
qap prime plus b p prime a will exactly
be equal to b q a this is because bqa is
an exterior angle in the Triangle qap so
its measure will be the sum of the other
two angles
now for any other point P Prime we know
that we can substitute in right here
so we have BPA is equal to qap prime
plus b p prime a
this angle q a p Prime will always be
greater than zero for any other point P
Prime and that shows that BPA will be
greater than b p prime a that's exactly
what we want it to prove so Point p is
the optimum viewing angle
now from here we just need to figure out
the distance op and we can do that using
the tangent secant theorem
so the square of the length of op is
equal to the length of OA multiplied by
the length of o b
so we have that OB will have a distance
that's equal to lowercase b and we have
that OA is equal to a distance that's
lowercase a
op we had said was equal to X so
substituting in x squared is equal to a
times B which is exactly what we had
before giving that X is equal to the
square root of a b now recalling that a
is equal to 32 and B is equal to 18 x is
equal to the square root of 32 times 18
giving that X is equal to 24 and that's
the answer
so it's interesting that we can solve
the problem in another way using only
geometry
what a question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]